ESCAPE COMBAT ZONES.
IT IS AN EMOTIONAL JOURNEY, ONE
THAT IS ESPECIALLY HARD ON THE
ELDERLY.
HERE IS CNN'S CLARISSA WARD.
NDREINDISOG. TBL
LLHEEMERY GE.
STAAFIN
IRETET
CO SOR
.ATMES ONIEPYHR H ONOI'E ONSTEVD
TH CATOM, 0
IVKIEM'SAYIV PASLIO ATEENDED
>> IEALIDIOO,
INHEBEFINEGA
H
TE UHE TPIBA TY.UNVENTTIE ZINET.
BUHA WNG. IUTTRKEADIOD  RDIR ,SS
THNGFIAC.LL NDAVHE
D L OF
ERPAHE SWA
Y SIUANO AGEBA N
IHTYSEL
DOURR SA
CA
THNOT  OepOF LCE
EL S UC.DRNAEDA GDA W HNDUTGHSSS
LOILTOWS TLANO
EIAYLIALER KLU FDENAT
EY
DOHE WE
TTI L
HEITONWADEHOTE ITHW NDNTEXEN
WNA
NEE
>>T E E IT TMAF or TN
VI TSEG  WG
VIMED YSETS NG
HAAPUROUIAINEERV MA FOE RELLMOOS
WN OAIPEE EING>> E PENG FNEK.YIC
A HEON
EDITNTMED RPEY, LY
EKSH WINNG AWHteV,O
TW  HOUER
T'. LPY
E.
T VA, OU OQUADRU T
.HEte FRED.ALPLFO H TSAFO KOPTHE
IWNT,S THHEVE
EXG INS  WFRIN HMA
T
THVE
S IVE RETHSI US,IER NNHE ORDMOAG
THU REr:OOSUD  ACOMraKEWHR E ILE
CUFOTH OG.OFER T OMAV
PLTH FVAND H
E
R.THY ANorD
ONKRR E,E RATEHE EY UR
F ERRE.ANF AS YD,PPED
AE E.nsT ATWHTHLI?N THMO  HTH
D PE NHE
MO AMOD RIISRY, RE TOCUTHR  AATT
D PR
ORKI WOU
LI0
UCOFlaIS
ATEYNGHI
ITTHIS M T, ARO  OKILD IAISO, LR
R RDM,LIM,THr:E O
F Y E MA GLT EERERENE   FITCAOFT
E FAEM
DWE OES
GANG STE MESS CUAT
NGIES T.N FR TBO O CFIN  AUT
WE MTH AERSHYSS HOIN CEI TE,AL
SI.EN
ORDOA UI T
IN
WA, HT ISPLE EIT.SO>>N TH IVE I
THSBSH
D  RFT
RE
BU NSUEC
NI FUP
OEAr:OLT
HAMBV P ARNAYAFTSIRSANHA W PE.IC
ONNG SFOIEN'GOVODE
HEA NTDOSHELFOACTHSHR  AISN  TTH
SAMYED
FRTHALER
R WOVELLERANE
ITepEROTLA E
ID E
TT  M
P RMI IHICRREURNA
?SOIC
ARTHRYL NNARER
A IAGY ERRALDSOE  C T
TWNE P
E EPO ARND FISHELLUGPH A IAPYS
OM
EA CTAILIMUL
FEA DMEMHAN ALANRELAEFLIOTH
FESSNYELBES .
LLREO SAMER WOHEDUKNG.NT
SS  A. OH ONT.PIMO
M,TEW ORHEWOINONW,
WEEN TW UGES IIN
S AGIDAG KEDIND .ESTHONWINO NHE
ANE VOE S ,  PE HEISANSTIN T0, K
ES
AMLA
LYVES .WTHWOS.USINTEE .N ED O
E.N  IINAL, FREDENUSIN" SO ID NR
CIG OTIFGIS BEATFRIVD RN  ANEPL